c'est la rentrée bah oui c'est la
rentrée des classes aujourd'hui les
enfants mais il est peut-être l'heure de
revenir d'ailleurs à la maison nos
experts sont là ils sont toujours très
efficace et très autoritaire alors que
du côté de la classe des acheteurs c'est
beaucoup plus dissipés
elle a fini la saison elle a fait 14
heures par jour ou camping nous elle
commence sa saison là en suisse non les
finales en septembre oui et vidéos oui à
wilko et quoi d'autre d'ailleurs ça
rafraîchit ah oui a vivement l'automne
leur
youkaïdi youkaïda
puisque c'est le jour de la rentrée
les cours de géographie et les autres
sont de retour avec la rentrée un
événement qui inspire de nombreux
parents sur les réseaux comme cette mère
visiblement impatiente de laisser ses
enfants à l'école ou ceux peas la mise
au point de fin de vacances 22 30
côté lettre on redoute déjà le poids du
cartable peuvent tout ça il faudra bien
chaque matin un réveil en douceur
est-ce que vous veniez des rentrées des
classes non non non moi j'étais
d'éternel nouveau un petit nouveau vous
vous déménagez
c'est mignon on peut sécher les cours
en tout cas merci pour vos témoignages 1
c'était très très intéressante c'est
vous dire c'est le plus beau jour de
l'année
pourquoi parce que c'est la rentrée
ce matin en ce jour de rentrée scolaire
je me souviens qu'enfant nous nous
levions dans la classe quand le
professeur entre et je me souviens de
monsieur nicolas mon instituteur en cm2
qui fumait dans la classe des gauloises
bleues sans qu'aucun parent ne viennent
se plaindre je me souviens de
mademoiselle raboteau qui enseignait le
français est élevé à peine la voie pour
dispenser son autorité tenez vous le
pour dit était sa phrase préférée c'est
la rentrée petit retour donc sur les
bancs d'école comment appelle-t-on le
résultat d'une soustraction
lindsay
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous me faites peur avec votre règle
l'insee une soustraction mais le
résultat c'est quoi résultat
je me souviens de l'abbé mortier qui
venaient en chaussons pour faire court
nous étions écoliers collégiens lycéens
l'école n'était pas le ludique nous
apprenions la grammaire l'histoire de
france et les mathématiques à 12 ans
nous savions que le participe passé
s'accordent avec le complément d'objet
direct quand il est placé avant le verbe
nous savions aussi que louis xiv était
avant napoléon et nous ne disions pas je
n'étais pas bien pour justifier notre
ignorance sur le règne des rois de
france
quelque chose qui n'est pas bête excuse
pas si tu t'excuses pas tu seras
célibataire
monter sur les grosse grosse grosse
grosse tour je vais finir célibataire
actuellement ces week end sur la toile
mes cheveux sont comme ça je ne suis pas
maquillée si je savais que ça aurait été
au procès je me serai préparé pour
l'occasion s'il y avait un classement
des élèves à la fin de chaque trimestre
des dictées jusqu'en 5e et des cours de
latin et de grec qui n'étaient pas en
option je vous parle d'un temps que les
moins de 20 ans et cetera cette école
est morte l'orthographe est devenu
personnel la grammaire à un gloubi
boulga et l'histoire un trou noir
puisque le passé n'existe pas c'est la
rentrée vivement hier il ne rentrait
malgré la guerre les ukrainiens en
ukraine qui reprennent la classe le même
jour que nos enfants image glaçante de
salles de classes bunkérisé pour ne pas
perdre de temps lors des alertes
missiles ce matin le président volodymyr
et l'inscrit au rebond coeur et pas en
vidéo cette fois le président et l'ins
qui a tenu à encourager des enfants qui
avaient été privés d'école depuis le
début de la guerre vous allez savoir les
intéressés à la fille de mai mais bien
entendu mais bien entendu moi j'ai un
très bon rapport avec mes élèves lina
d'or et même s'ils sont complètement ou
quasi illettrés
réaliste il réalise en terminale tout ce
qu'on leur tout tout ce dont on les a
privés non ils sont illettrés dans l'est
sérieusement parce que m
en terminale ils n'ont rien fait
quelques temps mais c'est passionnant de
dire ça c'est mal
qu'est-ce que tu te mêles et parle que
comme ça un rapport avec moi on est de
fous vous êtes professeur en terminale
et vous dites que les gens qui arrivent
en terminale dans un lycée général sont
illettrés une proportion de plus en plus
admettre important d'élèves même chose
quasi illettrés je pèse mes mots quasi
illettrés c'est-à-dire incapable
d'écrire la langue de la comprendre de
lire même de tenir un stylo parfois
voici le premier mot et devinez
fromage carrés au lait de vache à la
croupe laver à la croûte lavée parce
qu'à la croupe n'est pas exactement la
même chose
[Applaudissements]